las desigualdades estructurales en
américa latina y caribe tierra fértil
para la pandemia así lo revela el
reciente informe de amnistía
internacional que expone como las
inequidades que sufre la región
dispararon la letalidad del cob y 19 las
crisis preexistentes la falta de
infraestructura de inversión pública la
falta de priorizar el ejercicio
fundamental del derecho a la salud
durante décadas generó una tierra fértil
para que la pandemia de kobe 19 pues
llegara y afectará de manera
desproporcional a los países de américa
latina y el caribe la región
latinoamericana con el 28% de los
fallecimientos mundiales se convirtió en
el epicentro de la enfermedad según el
reporte que analizó los datos de 17
países el bajo gasto público en
protección social y sanidad pública por
parte de los estados incrementaron estas
cifras e impactaron directamente las
economías y vidas de los grupos
poblacionales más vulnerables siendo las
mujeres y los menores uno de los más
golpeados con el incremento de 16
millones de personas en pobreza extrema
44 millones de personas padeciendo
inseguridad alimentaria 21 millones de
ellos con inseguridad alimentaria severa
y el 30% de la población sin acceso a
salud pública este análisis desde la
perspectiva de derechos humanos permite
concluir que la desigualdad
socioeconómica de la región no es
meramente una consecuencia no deseada
sino el resultado concreto de acciones
discriminatorias e inequitativas además
de omisiones de los gobiernos de la
región una alarma que también expuso
recientemente la cepal señalando que el
desigual reparto de la riqueza conspira
contra la recuperación y contra el
desarrollo de la región por ello los
organismos de derechos están a los
gobiernos a tomar medidas efectivas y
una mayor inversión del gasto público
para paliar estas injusticias